the Joe Rogan experience people ask you
you why don't you have a take on this
right why haven't you tweeted about this
right like there was a the Christchurch
Massacre happened and I was reading
about it and I was like god damn this is
[ __ ] crazy and I'm reading about this
and this guy was a white nationalist and
he said hi to pudy pie before he went
and killed all his people I'm like what
the [ __ ] like what is this yeah and then
I never checked my mentions and then I
just was because I was on Twitter
looking at all this stuff I saw
something that led to something that
someone tagged me and then I looked at
my mentions for a second I'm like how
come you're not talking about
Christchurch you racist piece of [ __ ]
like it just happened yeah and I don't
have a take like what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to say rest in peace like what
is what does anyone want you to say when
a massacre happens this was horrible
everybody knows it's horrible yeah it's
a weird thing now if you don't denounce
something against people you're like
then you're on you're supporting it yeah
and you're like I'm just trying to with
me there's been situations where just
talking to people if they don't want you
talking to certain people because those
people are right-wing or those people
and if oh you must be secretly white
right-wing right I'm not I tell you I'm
not why don't you believe me it's a
weird thing like I'm a liberal gyres
call myself a 90s liberal before
everything went sideways yeah I'm not
like whatever you know woke it's
happening yeah yeah I'm a you know yeah
Alyssa Milano is calling for a sex
strike yeah I saw that look well that's
what you do when no once you [ __ ] you
anymore yeah start saying crazy [ __ ]
like when I have a stick we're gonna
have a sex strike ladies you're gonna
hold out like that and Tim Poole had the
best take on that he's saying so men who
agree with you won't get laid right like
what don't even make any sense like but
the idea that it's it's the same thing
we're talking about earlier they've
lumped men into this category like women
are gonna go on strike until we respect
their reproductive rights within Georgia
first of all it's just
he wants trike for the whole country
that's not gonna help Georgia I don't
know if you understand voting but that's
not how it works
there's state politics local politics
second of all like most men don't have
anything to do with this no we have men
meetings where we get together and say
hey we've got to stop these women from
dopes they're exercising their
reproductive rights right like you're
punishing a bunch of people that have
nothing to do with this because we also
have penises like what what's the
thought process there this is so but
it's such an obvious virtue signal
it's so obvious this is like [ __ ] hats
the woman's right we're gonna do this
we're gonna do this but and then we're
gonna we're gonna sex strike and a bunch
of her friends probably like yeah this
is gonna work like this is not how to
handle things it's not us I've never
voted against women's reproductive
rights right if you're telling like my
wife she can't [ __ ] me because if she
does she's not down for the cause like
we you're orchestrating everyone's sex
life that's crazy you're just gonna make
people angry at you it's a little
strange look at that guy's that guy's an
[ __ ] can I still get laid yeah
nothing he stinks no you can't and the
you know abortions such a [ __ ] creepy
subject too because it's such a
minefield like if you're a man and you
even talk about it like first of all why
are you talking about it has nothing to
do with you it's a woman's right to
choose and a woman's body like okay I
get it
yes but it's a thing so if it's a thing
you're allowed to talk about a thing
right
and this thing happens to be a fetus
that could become a Joe list or a Jamie
Vernon or a Joe Rogan or who the fights
it gonna be a person I think she's going
me Fernan that guy right there
oh hey Jay young Jamie so that if as the
fetus grow will become a person now I'm
not saying you shouldn't be able to
terminate the pregnancy I'm not saying
that but that is what it is it is it's
gonna be a person and to pretend
anything else it's like they don't no
one wants you to discuss it that way
like no one wants you to say that this
is a viable offspring it's going to be a
person someday no one wants you to say
that it's just oh there's code word it's
like a woman's right to choose there's
like these these ways of describing it
which I agree with them
not a pro-life person a pro-choice
person right but when it gets to be like
five months old and then people are
saying well that's just a woman's right
to choose okay okay it is it is it is
but that's a baby now
but that thing could live outside the
womb but isn't there isn't that law I
don't even read that the Georgia law but
isn't I don't know the Georgia law but
like this thing with now they can
late-term isn't that specifically if the
baby or mother is in danger
no no not everywhere in some places it
is in some places it's not in some place
you just have the right to have an
abortion up until a certain amount of
time and I think it varies I don't think
there's a federal guidelines I think
that's one of the reasons why Georgia
just instituted this six-week thing like
their thing is the moment the child is a
heartbreak the heartbeat and that
apparently is six weeks in right
sometimes people don't even find out
they're pregnant until seven eight nine
weeks in and they're saying they have to
carry the baby yeah it's a [ __ ]
minefield yeah it's a hard and like many
subjects people want it to be just kind
of black and white yeah but we need to
have a sex strike to soothe this out
yeah that's what it is
girls we're gonna go on a sex strike how
many women read that and like yeah none
I'm at a maybe maybe a few thousand few
crazy [ __ ] just out of their fun and
a few men like yes please take it away
from me please let me show I've hurt you
let me show my virtue yeah I imagine
it's a small amount
imagine being her husband which is a
growing on sex strike that's it sex
strike and she sees the [ __ ] the
Twitter post and she made a poster for
it like I put the little [ __ ] pink
ribbon and [ __ ] like good Christ he's
probably like it just he's probably
talking to his lawyer like what okay
what would I lose okay if we let if I
left right now like how much would I
have to pay like what if she can test
that okay and then how much of the legal
fees how many what is this like an
average amount of time you have to spend
in court
it's all men they all did it no sex for
any man until we get our rights well
it's a very similar I mean isn't that
the mindset of racism yes exact a
similar mindset of like Oh someone was
murdered these you know six guys in the
train were yelling at me
exactly no more Latinos on the train
yeah a hundred percent it's the same
things generalizations and the idea that
you have anything to do with other males
and it's even crazier than racism
because it's like the whole gender it's
the whole gender it's like not not just
like just white guys suck no like
[ __ ] everybody sucks nobody gets any
[ __ ] right for until we sort this out
yeah but I but do you think maybe a part
of it is just that what is this Jamie oh
this is Bridget my friend Bridget call
me but you know what's funny is yeah she
liked it Alyssa Milano liked it that's a
good joke she's got and it is she's
funny Bridget fantasy is very funny
[Applause]